It's no secret that 2016's Doctor Strange
is a part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
but just how connected is the Master of the
Magic Arts to his fellow superheroes and his
comic legacy?
Here are a few Doctor Strange Easter eggs
you may not have noticed.
New York, New York
The flow of time gets a little wacky in Doctor
Strange, thanks to the influence of the Eye
of Agamotto and the Infinity Stone powering
it.
But we can safely say that the film takes
place in a world that's well aware of superheroes.
During a few shots in the film, we see the
Avengers' tower standing tall over New York.
However, by the end of Age of Ultron, the
Avengers have abandoned the tower and moved
to upstate New York like Rhinebeck hipsters.
Either way, hero stuff is going on, so Strange
isn't alone.
War Machine?
Moments before master surgeon Stephen Strange
has the car accident that changes his life,
he hears about a 35-year-old with a spine
problem and an experimental suit of armor.
And despite an Easter egg dropped in Daredevil,
it's probably not Stilt-Man.
Mostly because no one would care if Stilt-Man
was paralyzed.
Tony Stark made pretty sure that no one was
flying around using any of his designs by
blowing up his entire arsenal at the end of
Iron Man 3, and we know that poor ol' Rhodey
suffered a pretty devastating spinal injury
during Civil War.
While the filmmakers have denied any connection,
how many people are really hanging out in
"experimental armor" in the MCU?
Shamballa
"What's this?
My mantra?"
"The WiFi password.
We're not savages."
The concept of Shamballa isn't unique to Doctor
Strange, as the mystical, otherworldly kingdom
has existed in religious texts for centuries.
Not coincidentally, Into Shamballa is also
the name of an important Doctor Strange story
from 1986, concerning not only the death of
the Ancient One, but also featuring Hamir,
the one-handed magic man from the temple in
the movie.
While the comics reveal that Hamir is actually
Wong's father, the film flipped the script
in so many ways that it's not likely that
this relationship translated to the big screen.
Drumm
Like most of Marvel's heroes have done at
one time or another, Doctor Strange has also
relinquished his title and let someone else
fly around in his Cloak of Levitation for
a while.
In the film, the now-dead guardian of the
New York Sanctum was simply called "Drumm."
Eagle-eared Marvel fans will recognize the
name as belonging to brothers Jericho and
Daniel Drumm, the latter of which was a voodoo
houngan.
Comic book things happen, and the two are
joined in spirit and become Brother Voodoo.
At one point, Jericho Drumm takes possession
of the Eye of Agamotto and takes the name
"Doctor Voodoo," who also happens to be the
Sorcerer Supreme.
It doesn't last forever, but it's clear that
the MCU is planting magical seeds everywhere.
The Doctor Strange movie's prelude comics
confirm that this dead guardian was, in fact,
Daniel Drumm.
Not only that, but the comics — and a brief
moment in the film — also feature Tina Minoru
as another Master of the Mystic Arts.
She's a secret practitioner of dark magic
in Marvel's Runaways, and mother of powerful
witch Nico Minoru.
So, the Runaways have basically been confirmed
in the MCU, and psychic pet dinosaurs can't
be that far behind, which is the greatest
thing ever.
The Living Tribunal
The hierarchy of power in Marvel Comics is
confusing, and even though there are only
a few big, bad guys in the MCU, it's already
reaching perplexing levels of power.
Thanos is no slouch, but he's not much without
his Infinity Stones.
Dormammu seems like a big deal, but he also
seems like a less-intelligent version of Galactus
so far.
So when Mordo mentions the Staff of the Living
Tribunal, you know stuff is going to get crazy.
"This is the staff of the Living Tribunal."
Though he's a bit obscure, the Living Tribunal
is one of Marvel's many godlike characters:
an enormous, all-powerful dude with a floating
head that has three faces.
He essentially keeps all the multiverses in
balance and only has one being above him in
terms of power.
No, actually it's this guy.
And somehow, some part of The Living Tribunal
is captured in a wooden stick in the middle
of nowhere.
Because magic!
The Wand of Watoomb and the Book of Vishanti
Doctor Strange has a few signature magical
items.
Among them are the Eye of Agamotto, which
causes no end of trouble for Strange in both
the film and the comics, and the Cloak of
Levitation.
Curiously missing is the Book of Vishanti,
which is basically Strange's bible and encyclopedia,
though it's probably locked up in Wong's well-guarded
library, right alongside the book that Strange
does use, the Book of Cagliostro.
If you've been watching Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.,
you know that there's another magical book
floating around the MCU at the moment as well:
the Darkhold, which actually shares a few
pages with the Book of Cagliostro.
Not to mention that the Book of Cagliostro
has a few pages that were actually written
by God.
And probably a few by James Patterson.
We also get a glimpse of one of Strange's
other signature weapons: the Wand of Watoomb.
Even though it's Wong who wields the item
in defense of the Hong Kong Sanctum, that
weird, knobby, horned stick is unmistakable.
Blu-ray replays will probably reveal even
more of Strange's armory locked up in the
Bleecker Street Sanctum.
Which, by the way, is located at 177A, just
like in the comics.
Nic West
The jealous, potato-chip-loving Doctor Nic
West is actually a character right out of
the pages of a 2007 Doctor Strange story called
"The Oath," where he plays the doctor who
bungles Strange's busted-up hands beyond usefulness.
He begins magical training, just like Strange,
but he's a C student at best.
Eventually, he accidentally kills someone
with magic, and he and Strange duke it out,
with West falling off a building to his death.
And that scene where an astral Strange helps
someone with an operation on his own mortal
body?
Straight out of "The Oath," too.
Mindless Ones
The Dark Dimension basically has three main
inhabitants: Dormammu, his sister Umar, and…
"The mindless ones!"
Those guys are Dormammu's featureless, grey,
cycloptic hench-things.
At the conclusion of Doctor Strange, we see
Kaecilius and his minions get sucked into
the Dark Dimension, losing all their features
in the process … and looking suspiciously
like Mindless Ones during their transformation,
with glints of light replacing their faces.
It seems likely that anyone who allies with
Dormammu and his promise of eternal life will
eventually be transformed into a Mindless
One.
What this means for the Ancient One?
We may never know…
The Doors of Perception
The obligatory Stan Lee cameo was so much
more than just an old dude reading on the
bus.
The book that Lee is giggling at is The Doors
of Perception by Aldous Huxley.
Not only is it a literal reference to Strange's
perception of reality being forced open, but
the book is pretty much an essay about a psychedelic
drug trip, which is no small comment on both
the dazzling special effects of the movie,
and the Dark Dimension.
That place looks like a Steve Ditko drawing
come to life, and it's practically a spitting
image of those 1970s Third Eye blacklight
posters Marvel used to sell for your parents'
teenage drug dens.
"Ohhhh!"
"Wow, man!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel and watch more videos like
the one you just saw.
And don't forget to check out all this cool
stuff we know you'll love, too!